so many strange things have happened to
me I was so sick I was suffering so much
I can remember when I had my hip and
Ankle replaced I was in so much pain it
was unbelievable for an entire year like
broken bones but like not able to be
fixed and I remember thinking at that
point that like something had to be real
like I didn't know if God was real but
that amount of pain and suffering like
something evil had to be real and then
things were just super weird with my
life like being that ill like
unbelievably stupidly like job level ill
and then like fixing it with a diet that
like nobody believed right like what is
that about and then having my mom get
really sick and then my dad get really
sick and then my dad get famous for like
it's just things have been so absurd
that it's like yeah well that stuff
could have happened life's pretty weird